alors qu'il ya quelques semaines la
menace d'un confinement nationale
l'année sur la france ces derniers jours
ont été ceux d'une stagnation de
l'épidémie qui a permis d'éviter le pire
nous allons continuer cette stratégie
mais ce week-end le beau temps était
présent en france et qui dit beau temps
dit activités en extérieur
faut quand même profité de la venue à
montpellier face à paris bordeaux
marseille ou encore lille des scènes
similaires sur les quais dans les parcs
et les zones touristiques de nombreuses
personnes parfois sans masque ils
profitent entre amis du retour des beaux
jours
en baissant la garde face aux gestes
barrières personne n'est vraiment aux
fans de respecter la loi dans certains
quartiers la police a dû intervenir pour
rappeler les gestes de dispensation à
adopter et pour presser les badauds à
rentrer avant le couvre feu de 18h alors
êtes vous choqué par le relâchement des
français alors êtes vous choqué par le
relâchement des français au point cette
question à 19h46
et juste avant qu'on ait des réponses je
voudrais vous remonterez on a fait une
petite compil des stores y installer sna
partout en france ce week-end
et moi je vous dis hein j'ai pas un pote
j'ai pas une personne qui m'ont pas dit
qu'ils avaient une soirée ce week-end je
vous racontais il ya des soirées
clandestines qui se passe de plus en
plus je vous dire comment ça se passe
maintenant c'est juste incroyable
regarder ça je vous dire après c'est
très très très organisés c'est parti
et oui alors juste pour les soirées
quand on décide de vous dire comment ça
se passe maintenant
donc il ya des gens qui payent des
vigiles en bas qui tourne en voiture qui
préviennent voit la cia lequel finance
voilà donc un truc de fou un jean bien
un d une organisation incroyable
la soeur qui sont au coin de la rue et
qu'ils reviennent comme au fond dans les
demandes et les endroits où il ya des
ventes de stupéfiants qui prévient les
organisateurs pour dire calmez vous
mettiez la musique ça y'a les keufs
qu'arrive ouais c'est ça et maintenant
ce qu'il faut aussi c'est que tu es un
truc mokaké est assez drôle mais qu'il
faut pas faire c'est que ils ont ils
invitent tout tout l'immeuble en fait
donc maintenant tout le monde voilà
comme on dit à la soirée donc maintenant
il ya plus de problème voilà ou parfois
même ils dédommagent chasse et sachez le
oui oui oui ils doivent dédommager les
voisins en leur disant voilà on va vous
donner un petit billet de voilà de
cinsault quand même un gros billets de
500 euros voire parfois 1000 euros je
vous le dis et pour voilà qu'ils fassent
comme s'il s'était rien passé
donc c'est extrêmement organisés
maintenant il ya des moyens pour les
soirées étaient des moyens de fou alors
on en parlait justement est-ce que vous
êtes choqués par le relâchement des
français merci anne j'ai noté d'être
avec nous merci vous êtes député en
marche mais tient déjà avant tout matin
avant tout plus député remarque des
français d'asie porte parole des députés
en mars à l'assemblée merci d'être là
anne
c'est la première fois que vous venez
sur le plateau j'espère que ça va bien
se passer et par année vous allez avoir
enfin vient la voir en face de vous
c'est quand même c'est chez quelqu'un
fabrice di vizio avocat comment ça va
fabrice à lui si je vois j'ai
l'impression que ça n'arrive à me calmer
et à la voix la maison pas très bien
elle est très jolie et très d'airbus
c'est un médecin la halle a tout pour
elle a donc voilà donc je peux
comprendre les chéris juste avant
d'entendre fabrice di vizio et anne
gendt et j'aimerais avoir votre avis
vous est ce que vous comprenez ou est-ce
que vous êtes choqués par le relâchement
des français donc à libé devaient d
alors qu'elle était très choqué à
l'époque
eh ben j'ai été très choqué mais je
change souvent d'avis parce que ben
parce qu'on voit que ça évolue et que
chacun ne sait pas trop ce qui se passe
donc moi je change d'avis aussi j'ai le
droit
je vais vous dire la vérité moi samedi
soir j'ai fait une petite heure non ça
va on était six bon ça va maintenant si
ça va on essaie si vous êtes dans les
roches noires
ça va je vais vous dire la vérité on
s'est éclatés savoir tellement du bien
mais c'était juste mais on peut
s'éclater à 6 ramé est franchement mais
moi voyons
10 il a fait une fête avec tous ces
femmes ces enfants qu'ils étaient 250
oui oui alors après parce qu'on va pas
laisser parler d'autres il faut vous
dire la vérité je suis passé au canal
saint martin samedi après midi
j'ai vu des milliers de jeunes non
masqué en train de s'amuser
alors je sais que c'est pas bien mais
franchement ça m'a fait du bien pour eux
faut pas le faire j'ai vraiment je
n'incite personne n'a le faire mais j'ai
vu des gens heureux et ça m'a fait du
bien pour eux mais faut pas le faire
j'ai eu le verbe est ce vous d'être
choqués vous bien c'est totalement
irresponsable
moi je suis maintenant pour
l'interdiction de vendre de l'alcool sur
la voie publique c'est parce que ça
incite les gens à sortir on assiste à un
relâchement les chiffres remontent on a
vu des scènes folle et comme on nous dit
mais bientôt il y aura des concerts et
puis bientôt le public viendra dans les
stades
les consignes sont contradictoires les
gens ne comprennent plus rien les beaux
jours ci et si on ne réagit pas
maintenant
l'épidémie va repartir de plus belle
alors la reine de la night qui est très
impacté par les soirées vous dites ne
regagneront la tension il ya deux choses
moi les soirs et fermés ça je suis
contre et tout ça mais je trouve qu'on
déplace les problèmes et je dénonce un
peu une hypocrisie j'ai vu une image
vous savez ce qui m'a le plus choqué ce
week-end c'est pas les foules de la
sorec quel niveau de votre saison
ces deux policiers qui demandaient ada2
personne assise sur un banc qui était
sans masque de leurs maîtres
je suis désolé on déplace à vous a
choqué sont déplacés dans les longs et
moi je plonge les cds nous obligés
depuis des mois à mettre le masque
dehors et contre productif parce qu'on
n'en peut plus et on l'est on le faisait
merveille à boire et fabrique division
alors les médecins réputés en marge des
français daddy qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous vous êtes choqués par
par son relâchement je suis un peu
ennuyé quand ma main je vais pas dire
que je vais sauter au plafond joie en
même temps j'ai quand même vu des gens
sur les images que vous avez montré là
cette image là par exemple juste avant
les gens qui dansent ils ont tous le
masque oui ce sont deux raisons le
masque pas de problème et dansent ils
sont heureux les gens qu'on a vues dans
la rue qui boivent un coup et ce
problème c'est que certains mettent pas
leur masse ou de suite c'est ça la
difficulté est aujourd'hui même si en
extérieur et sait à quel point ce que
sont moins importants ils sont pas
nulles et en plus on sait qu'aujourd'hui
ça a été rapide ce matin la différence
c'est qu'on a
malheureusement des données qui montrent
que des combes est le masque le risque
qu'il est déjà là voilà alors alors je
veux pas faire peur à tout le monde mais
si on fait tout ça super et fort on va y
arriver alors je lis je vous préviens
juste anne
il est nerveux fabrice division j'ai
déjà pratiqué bien il ya il ya deux
problèmes comme toujours
1 est ce que vous vous rendez compte du
poids des mots le relâchement des
français bon qu'est ce que c'est que
cette façon poser les questions
les français se re la rose art les
français sont des enfants est
effectivement qui jusqu'ici étaient des
enfants sages
et maintenant il se relâche alors si on
voulait commencer pas rater le savant
utiliser aller dans la rue quand il fait
beau c'est pas un relâchement c'est
normal premier régulièrement 1ère 2ème
et des mois vous des fonds de madame le
député est ce que vous pourriez de
nouveaux pardonner mais c'est une
question rituelle ici est ce que vous
pourriez me donner deux études non pas
une mais deux études qui vous disent
effectivement que le masque à
l'extérieur et bien change quelque chose
et l'épidémie est-ce que vous avez des
éléments
même le haut conseil de santé publique
vous dit effectivement que le masque à
l'extérieur oh non c'est inutile sauf
dans des circonstances très
particulières
donc à un moment donné si vous voulez
moi je veux bien qu'on me parle du
relâchement
je veux bien ici et là tout le monde a
un avis sur tout mais sur quoi le fond
dé vous alors quoi la sq au point de
donner deux études je voudrais
simplement rappeler ça on a tous compris
maintenant que ça marche de porter un
mano à mano
à l'intérieur un monde désire n'en avons
pas de l'extérieur la marche des
étudiants de se laver les mains
ça m'a jamais l'avoir gardé ses
distances d'habitude sur ce plateau
c'est pas répondre aux questions qu'on
pose je ne suis pas un tribunal
si je marque simplement c'est pas un
argument tribunal sa céda sophistique je
pose une question précise
c'est simple est-ce que vous avez des
études qui vous disent que le masque en
extérieur ça marche
oui ou non est ce qu'il ya un endroit
aujourd'hui oui mais ce qu'il ya un
endroit mais il est terrible est-ce que
je peux bien mme affret madame vous
pouvez tenter votre chance il vous
répond ce matin vous répond madame vous
gaspillez pas votre question on a un
temps imparti est ce que oui
parce qu'à l'extérieur ça marche
d'hommage a eu besoin de 3 ha oui ou non
est ce qu'il ya des études qui montrent
que ça marche et que ça a une influence
des avocats vous avez bien un quart du
prix qui sont peu connus ou l'impasse
je suis désolé je mets sur salaire à
chaque fois que j'ai quelqu'un en face
il est infoutue pour répondre avec ecône
ise vous venez de m'expliquer quand vous
êtes gêné parce que les français ne
porte pas de masque à l'extérieur et que
c'est pas bien je vous dis que tout ça
est fait pour lutter contre l'épidémie
l avez vous des éléments qui vous
permettent de dire que sa lutte contre
l'épidémie comme un pc des commerçants
conseil de santé publique vous dit la
berce
alors avez vous des éléments anpaa je
peux parler alors allez-y dame alice
m'en rappeler simplement qu'aujourd'hui
il ya effectivement un département et
sur lesquelles il ya des mesures de port
du masque obligatoire qui vont être
prises dans les lieux publics hautement
fréquenté non pas partout on peux
continuer à aller en forêt sans porter
de masque on est tous c'est impossible
donc ça c'est sarah possible je veux
rappeler le déni je veux dire à ce que
nous avons dit comme ça ça avec une
heure sont d'une précision sa
connaissance attendait fabrice on va
voir ce que nous avons vu là nous avons
vu des français qui profite d'un moment
de beau temps et va y en avoir encore
plus c'est une bonne chose
on leur demande simplement à tous
notamment dans les alpes maritimes
notamment en moselle notamment dans le
département du nord marie ville de
dunkerque on leur demande s'il vous
plaît
c'est super compétent pouvoir mais on
leur demande pourquoi ils ça a été on
vous demandez à des français de porter
un masque à l'extérieur je vous demande
sur quel fondement de porter un masque
également alain malgré l'ajout des mâles
de l'extérieur sur quel fondement
avez vous une étude qui me disent que le
masque à l'extérieur a une utilité
là où il s'agit d'un trait
un argument très simple alors allez-y
sait ce qui l'attend alors argument très
sympa c'est ça marche c'est que moi
quand on a commencé à dire qu'il fallait
rendre le masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur j'ai dit ok mais on va vous
embêter avec votre truc je vais pas le
mettre la levée le maître l'enlever je
le mets en sortant de chez moi comme ça
on n'entend plus parler globe et de fête
et de fait donc je le mets tout le temps
également extérieur
je ne sais pas d'où ça m'a rassuré wars
est bien rodée janvier alors que jordan
exemple au japon d'un sens du jeu me
convient c'est en voyant la situation du
japon j'imagine la me souvenais
sélectionneur sont la corée et bien
sensible
c'est ce site il ya les jeunes amateurs
donner des sensations qui les ont
respecté alors à fonctionner l'épidémie
va motiver les problèmes de ce pays
c'est que l'épidémie elle est gérée
comme ça avec des exemples avec des
exemples pardon mais halak ont augmenté
alors f a brisé le marbre les divisions
pour l'instant n'y a pas eu de rencontre
il n'y a pas eu de troisième
on parle de re lâche mon chien je vois
je sais bien que la shdm en madame s'il
ya un relâchement c'est la question qui
est posée
je vous m'avez vous m'expliquer que vous
avez été quelque peu perturbée par ces
français qui ne porte pas le masque à
l'extérieur je voudrais juste vous
demander sur quoi se fonde votre gêne
avez vous un argument scientifique qui
nous disent que porter un masque à
l'extérieur est bien en digne l'épidémie
où un état sur celle ci oui ou de dire
que la danse que nous avons vu les
personnes qui ont enlevé leurs masques
et qu'ils se parlent
oui à moins d'un mètre les unes des
villes où il ya danger est là mais les
études radar vous n'aimez se le dire une
idée de même sans masque
tom gilbert va juste pour voir parce que
vous avez des éléments là dessus j'ai
les chiffres m e division et sont moins
fantaisiste vous nous avez amené la
semaine on parle de relâchement n'y a
pas que les masques les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui les entrées en réanimation
il devait déjà fait ce coup là monsieur
c'est de réchauffer ça c'est
d'aujourd'hui où on n'a pas effectué je
te dis que c'est son domaine du fret
aujourd'hui côté écoutez moi même pas 25
en temps quelques jours mais laissez moi
juste finir mon argument c'est un film
suit alors les seuls à venir après vous
allez voulait effectivement faire du
show vous pouvez lui faisant la
contradiction c'est possible mais ceci
dit moi ce que je vous demande vous avez
des chiffres d'entrées en réanimation
fort bien bris et je le déplore
maintenant effectivement établie c'est
moi que s'échine corrélation entre sont
dus à ce que tous lui appelé
maladroitement le relâchement des
français avez vous un élément à ce sujet
monsieur mais bien sûr que j'en ai les
50 entré en réunion à surveiller à la
fosse de 25 à 35 ans du relax urvoas et
voulons vous savez compter les yeux moi
je sais compter mais vous manifestez
vous ne savez pas parler et vous n'avez
aucune idée ce qu'un argument parce que
depuis tout à l'heure à avancer des
chiffres l'homme je vous demande un lien
de causalité
c'est pas que très peu oublié à
comprendre non plus je vous demande
déclinante avancer un chiffre
dites moi que ces chiffres est corrélé à
quelques est ce qui a posé problème pour
en arriver là où nous en sommes mais
vous m'expliquer que nous sommes à 50
vous vivez dans une grande première
vivait dans une grotte dont vous ne
saurez jamais même que je vais vous
donner un conseil
et je vous assure que c'est un conseil
pertinent quand vous n'êtes pas en
plateau essayer de regarder les études
qui sont publiés vous apprendrez
beaucoup de choses et ça vous a un
avantage c'est un peu moins idiot sur
les plateaux excusez moi mais on en
donne et on parle effectivement de
choses sérieuses à des fonctionnaires
polonais a cédé lesquels vous n'entendez
d'un orient poignet
ne manquez rien du livre monsieur vous a
cédé des chiffres qui ne veulent rien
dire et depuis tout à l'heure personne
n'est en mesure de me dire à quoi sont
liés ces chiffres alors petit comme
l'appelait en écosse où se contaminent
bonne tête on va voir luis salom
première manif à nice en herbe années 30
mais demain avec un vrai compliment
cours deuxième vague
aujourd'hui cinquante mille morts avec
un semi confinement serait que les gens
le droit de sortir un chat donc la
question complète nos bas parce que sa
deuxième palier comme que la question la
question que je pose c'est d'ailleurs
ici vous êtes quoi pour un confinement
total d'un mois qui permettrait d rien
pouvoir vivre normalement dès vous avez
cette particularité sur ce plateau
quand vous savez pas répondre à une
question vous y répondez par une
question qui est vraiment temps que vous
posez en cassation at elle dit n'ont ils
pas tous nos routes à grand chose est
sûre je vous oppose vous savez quand
même que décisions qu'on prend
elles sont fondées sur une rationalité
et pas juste sur la vie de blé des
chroniqueurs et et pnt quand même pas
j'espère que son mouvement allait
j'entends bien monsieur mais si vous
remarquez le cinéma moi si vous
remarquez la différence entre vous et
moi c'est que je ne donne pas mon avis
mais je vous demande sur quoi vous
permet lui donnerait une réponse vous
avez des incapables
là où moi je m'attendais - joe doody
quand même que s'agissant des masques à
l'extérieur
le haut conseil de santé publique vous
dire exactement qu'il n'apporte aucun
élément pertinent à ce sujet le conseil
d'état l'a lui même reconnu dans une
décision d'août dernier
premier élément les masques à
l'intérieur vous avez des études qui
sont largement contradictoires sur cette
question non non vraiment ça non non non
donné alors que nicolas effectivement en
mars on la confie les deux pays
ça c'est bon ça vous commencez une
réponse est venue écouter son film mille
morts déjà dit mais mises à part ces
trois nouveaux films
il semble que maintenant monsieur nous
ça veut dire quoi d'autre ça veut dire
quoi d'autres questions à poser au
plateau mais tout cela c'est que vous a
parlé et j'entends bien que vous vouliez
parler mais pourquoi pas aussi à barr
amour quoi diable personne car avec 11,5
à votre question je pose sur cinq
organisations ouais hein où se
contaminent ton quels sont les lieux de
contamination et deux sur quoi les
fondez vous sépare alors midi comme
question alors jean-michel merde oui je
ne vais pas vous faites votre retour
parce qu'il va y verront ce qu'on se
connaît pas je vais mettre vie que vous
êtes d'accord
la fois lavalas black fois alors tout
cas vous n'êtes pas mettre ça c'est sûr
et alors on cas là vous êtes plus malin
que vous faites partie de tout les gens
qui
mais moi non plus mais moi je suis
contre le relâchement il se voit pas
maintenant il verra dans quinze jours
trois semaines cela qu'on verra la gmn
reprenez les manifs c'est que même mon
nez quand on attendait plus monde est
contre vous auprès des gens mais très
mauvaise est un bon exemple
on nous avait dit attendez les manifs
traoré mon dieu quelle horreur vous
allez voir les gens dansent coûteux
les deux boîtes plein il s'est rien
passé berlin on nous avait dit pendant
les manifs de berlin mais ça aucune
catastrophe
il s'est bien passé ça prouve quoi vas-y
c'est parce quand même des chiens dans
les affaires sont mauvaises
vous avez du nord
joe souvenais plus qu'à des ministres de
la santé exposées n'est rien moins que
lui est ce que vous savez ces 6 patients
vaccinés mais ça fasse rien qu'on est
ensemble moi messieurs autant pas de
vacciner à ce projet belge espace rien
qu'on en groupe mais le premier a
répondu vous dit toujours que vous
répondez pas répondait messieurs
pourront accéder cultiver sénart de
l'approximation
là où il faut être précis mais lui
surtout lui la version sans proposer de
solution mais la merci de ses salles ça
si on allait mettre de solutions à ben
c'est pas vrai madame c'est pas moi qui
les deux mois je vous écoute moissonner
cerisier effectivement les agressions
vous l'auriez également testé tracé
isolés at-on bien c'est ce qu'on vous ça
vient des taux italiens des filtres à
sectionner ça à parce que vous le faites
pas parce que vous le faites pas si vous
l'avez capable de travailler et nous la
libation aujourd'hui je faisais moi
c'est une blague
et on est capable de dire où les
patients se contaminent mais l'on doit
les tracés et de les isoler vraiment une
déception il devrait téléspectateurs
vous dit que la france est capable de
faire ça non eh ben je vais je vais vous
dire il ya même eu un cas très précis et
y en a beaucoup tous les jours à la cij
internet outil a raconté ça prendrait du
temps
non mais aucun cas d'une personne qu'ils
vont être rentré en france en passant
par plusieurs villes européennes qui est
arrivé à paris gare du nord qui s'est
fait contrôler quels un pcr positif et
qui est à l' isolement arrêté
préfectoral prononcée contre alors les
pannes isolement n'ont pas aidé c'est
pas mal quand il s'est amusé alors
fabriquée à sa maison
oui parce que moi je suis dans mon cas
la salle s'est pas attardé je suis
avocat ça tombe de médecins dont
d'aéroport et qui depuis le mois d'août
a appelé goût de la phrase de philippe
juvin la phrase la france et le club
mais c'est pas lui que je promets
excusez moi
cette année c'est le club mène on ne
teste personnes
les gens peuvent entrer en france comme
dans un moulin c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est philippe jugera du moins de temps
que vous racontera mais attendez quant à
laon libre je vais terminer ce point
jusqu'à ya encore trois semaines à
roissy ça a probablement changé à cause
du variant anglais je le concède mais
jusqu'à il ya encore trois semaines j'en
ai 15000 où on pouvait arriver en france
sans se faire tester donc allez pas
maintenant sûr si vous voulez il ya un
dernier point auquel vous n'avez
toujours pas répondu et c'est là où je
peux ou là où je parle effectivement
d'approximations sait où se contaminent
ton jeu c'est quand même pas compliqué
alors qu'il ferait panda est ce que vous
les réponses confine pas
on est tout seul au milieu d'une heure
déserte au tamis connu plein ensemble à
l'évidence mer par exemple d'avocats
pour comprendre ça à vrai qu'on revienne
pas sur tous les tweets qui ont été
postées ce week-end notamment par mon
ami christophe dechavanne regardez qui a
posté un tweet
regardez christophe qui a réagi un tweet
de quelqu'un ici en train de chercher
l'étape christophe dechavanne sur google
non il sait le sait direct voilà merci
voilà regarder parmi cet après-midi
masse porter la réflexion distanciation
si elle est respectée au millimètre et
c'est pas comme si on avait un variant
plus contagieux et donc c'est pas
christophe qui a dit ça mais christophe
a réagi le canal saint-martin cet après
midi merci regarder adressé ses voeux
leur merci à tous ces connards qui
foutent des mois d'efforts en l'air au
nom de la bière jeunesse sacrifiée qu'il
dise jeunesse qui sacrifient les autres
plus tôt et il y en a d'autres y en a eu
plein comme ça voilà avec des photos
voilà cluster ensemble alors j'aimerais
d'abord canada agisse là dessus est-ce
que ça ça vous fait réagir vous êtes
d'accord avec ces gens qui ont été un
petit peu violence je verrai pas dans
les mêmes termes et ça fait la peine ça
fait la peine pour tous ceux qui
derrière vont se retrouver contaminées
vont contaminer leur grand père leur
grand-mère ou avoir des proches qui vont
décider puisque c'est ça la réalité vont
avoir je rappelle que 20 % des gens font
un kovy très très long qui n'en finit
pas ont décéléré pendant longtemps c'est
pas un petit mêmes et c'est pas une
petite même les plus jeunes la fin des
voiles fait pas exactement la moitié des
patients hospitalisés en rien ma ils
sont jeunes c'est pas c'est pas des plus
âgés ont pas forcément des comorbidités
donc voilà où c kon maladies sérieuses
et 84 mille morts aujourd'hui c'est la
quatrième cause de décès en france
ah ouais quand même faut pas l'oublier
on faire bientôt dépasser les morts par
accident alors d'autant plus qu'on a
moins d'accidents ce moment on va
rejoindre les maladies cardiovasculaires
enfin on en est où la balle et c'est
qu'à ce pied on est d'accord on est
contraint mais franchement on sait que
les efforts ont payé on le voit bien
après le premier confinement après
deuxième confinement là les efforts
qu'on a faits le plateau qu'on avait
atteint qui est en train de baisser
franchement aller on tient le bon bout
faut y aller faut aller un cran plus
loin vous êtes choqués voce défini oui
mais ses divisions
on est d'accord il va te défoncer
vois tu la capelle là il va te casser je
le connais peut-être que les particules
ne sont pas dans l'air lorsqu'on parle
mais en tout cas lorsqu'on parle ou
postionne on est d'accord que le
postillon et contaminant oui non oui
donc quand on est quelque part même si
on est à l'extérieur qu'on boit on boit
un peu beaucoup d'alcool qu'on chante qu
on exulte c'est normal qu'on postionne
c'est humain à partir de ce moment là si
les gens sont sans masque forcément
juste pour l'instant ça comptables finn
d'excusés et leurs soldats arrivent à le
calmer mais c'est tout simple village du
comice passé pour la première on chérit
n 10 me take on est hyper t ce soir mais
nous sommes au bout d'un moment faut
comprendre aux réalités de saint seiya
un petit plaisir éphémère et on risque
d'aller sur une troisième ronde de tous
sortir définitivement de réalité que
vous décrivez qui sont distinctes
et si vous voulez ce que je dénonce dans
cette crise c'est une comment je vais
dire une confiscation du raisonnement
nous n'avons plus le droit de réfléchir
dès que nous commençons à émettre une
réflexion où on est traité de
complotiste ou a effectivement on nous
rappelle les 80 mille morts dont
personne ne conteste la réalité c'est
pas le pr j'ai été le premier à faire un
recours pour les masques obligatoire à
l'intérieur pendant le gouvernement
tergiversait
donc c'est pas à moi qu'il faut dire que
je pars donc pas de calais tuer le
pardon j'ai maintenant je sais pas où
les problèmes à la différence de vous
c'est moi qui est capable de citer mais
sous se fonde sur un avis du conseil
scientifique du mois de mai en
particulier ça se fonde sur une étude de
stanford du mois de juillet où il avait
laissé sa seule sonde effectivement sur
une étude de yale du mois de juillet
alors évidemment c est le film tel que
vous filmez vous contrer ces études ont
été remises en question madame dans la
même façon que je viens de faire un
recours je me suis fait jeter par le
conseil d'état pour avoir des ffp2 dans
les transports parce que le conseil
d'état considère qu a pas d'urgence à
ben bon alors à un moment donné si vous
voulez c'est pas à moi qu'il faut parler
de protection je pense que j'ai acquis
mes lettres de noblesse sur la
protection de la population
simplement à un moment donné ce que vous
dites madame efforts juste mais ça c'est
de l'individualisme au sens où vous ne
pouvez pas raisonner en épidémiologie
sur des cas individuels et sur des
exemples sa démarche amicale ils ont
tendu la main
la masse tous nos gens là ils auraient
dû vous voulez prendre le jeu terminé
mais le même aujourd'hui denis n'ont pas
de notion et j'attends que madame le
député qui connaît ces questions parker
me le disent à bout nous l'exemple d'un
kloster à l'extérieur kloster assez
bonne très bonne question
il était il est exceptionnel les
clusters on a un cluster à partir du
moment où vous avez un groupe de
personnes rassemblées à moins d'un mètre
qui se présente sans masque qui parle
vous avez la possibilité d'un cluster
drian c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand on
évite ces rassemblements quand on les
limites quand on se freine quand on se
restreint on a les effets concrets avec
une régression est ce qu nombre
d'hospitalisations et surtout du nombre
de messes que vous vous rend je crois
surtout que les propos que vous tenez
depuis tout à l'heure vous voulez
absolument nous démontrer dans le fait
que vous criez prouve que vous êtes
absent de nos peines
non mais certainement la preuve que j'ai
une chance en vous je vous voyais son
disciple sinon madame la différence
madame c'est que vous depuis tout à
l'heure vous n'avez aucun argument 0 par
un magicien arguments non madame de
l'est vous êtes député déconfit mada
rigueur dont vous êtes né du dossier
cités de ce que nous avons fait nous et
les éditions que nous avons prise
oralement mais vous et là des
multinationales et nous n'avons pas une
seconde vague sont connus et brive ou
tel député de haskell vous êtes député
de la nation
les appareils mis à part oui il parait
effectivement vous êtes à les démazouter
de la nation alors là vous êtes député
de la nation cependant je note une chose
c'est que depuis tout à l'heure je vous
pose une question simple quel sont les
études sur lesquelles vous vous fondez
vous croyez moi j'ai su répondre a
ajouté me posais j'ai une et une seule
et unique question à vous poser est elle
importante
vous êtes député de lévis sur les études
qui vous montre le mort de pascal effet
rien d une efficacité de m'interpeller
comme parlementaire oui eh bien je vous
réponds comme parlement parce que les
médecins aussi j'avais les médecins
avant tout meilleurs
et donc parler des décisions qui ont été
prises de décisions politiques ont été
prises ça je peux vous en parler
sur quoi se fondent notamment chez en
revanche vous parlez de la comparaison
des études scientifiques des données je
laisse ça au conseil son verdict nous
sommes là n'en soit exactement là où
nous sommes c'est que nous y sommes et
ces gens-là nous demandons à quelqu'un
décide de son raisonnement il n'accable
comment voulez vous discuté après sa non
mais m la parole comme ça on n'est pas
évidemment c'est fini ça non mais oui
mais personne ne vous la donner a déjà
castaldi qui attend depuis tout à
l'heure vous avez alors une castaldi
sages dont savent bien jouer le sage non
honnêtement m vous êtes très bon en
rhétorique vous êtes parfait vous vous
parlez législatives quand il faut pas
aider loi vous parlez médecine quand tu
veux pas une médecine vous mélangez tout
pour avoir raison et à chaleur on vous
argumente quelque chose vite
montrez-moi l'étude mais jusqu'à preuve
du contraire je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas et c'est il faut
porter un masque d'euros pas mais le
fait est que tous les médecins du monde
entier depuis maintenant je sais pas
combien d'années une dizaine d'années
pour ne pas contaminer l'autre que ce
soit du second fini sa phrase j'aime
infiniment triste que depuis des
décennies la médecine fait porter des
masques pour éviter la contamination
d'un virus qu'elle gré il se trouve que
les asiatiques depuis des années porte
de masque quand ils prennent l'avion
allait en stocker suffisamment 2 et qui
sont que eux ont été partiellement moins
touché que nous alors je ne sais pas ce
qui est bon ou pas mais dans le doute
mettre dans le doute
dans le doute moi je vous conseille de
mettre un masque maintenant vous allez
expliquer à temps de deux secondes vous
m'expliquez par a plus b cas de la loi
qui a pas de bouaké pas d'étude moi je
vous dis que c'est complètement
suicidaire de dire aujourd'hui à
l'intérieure française que le masque à
l'extérieur ou l'intérieur points block
il y eu deux vies parce que on se bat
tous contre un virus qui nous casse les
pieds depuis des semaines et que dans le
doute
même si c'est totalement inutile m
laisser des gens porter un masque dedans
dehors mais parce que ça vous est fixé
par a plus b a pas de lois que nahla
france 2 monsieur c'est que je ne le
crois pas autorisé à donner le moindre
conseil aux falla c'est ça la différence
entre nous et la cimade conseil donne
son avis aux gens c'est que ce qu'ils
doivent penser mme patate
moi j'aurais pas cette légitimité les
croyants ne trouve dans nos cerveaux le
juriste est toujours celui qui interroge
le bien fondé des mesures c'est tout et
je ne t'avais fond sur faïence
particulière je note avec une acuité
particulière monsieur que vous nous
disiez fonds se fera depuis
est ce que vous vous rendez compte de ce
que vous dites juste un instant que tu
te rends compte de ce que tu décision
d'armer les uns et les autres et c'est
que la mission par lit tous les virages
et je trouve qu'ils aient droit à ces
jeux cette jolie des dizaines d'années
dans l'approximation vraiment donc je
sais ce que je dis je sais pourquoi je
le dis aux missionnaires lite mais
dites-moi la régression de l'est que des
contaminations et ne recule de
réalisation sur quoi on essaie de les
observer c'est l'étonnant moderne et
plusieurs fois comment ça il ya une
semaine
est ce que vous allez mettre noir sur
blanc confèrent le b madrid veut donc je
considère que les mesures qui ont été
prises étaient de bonnes mesures a bien
vous allez voir de considérer mais le
problème madame je pense quand même pas
dire avant sa mise le problème les
français sont tout à fait des magasins
certains d'entre eux pour une majorité
d'entre eux bon mais maintenant le
problème des femmes n'est pas savoir sur
le principe d'accord ou pas madame c'est
qu'à un moment donné vous imposer le
port du masque certains lieux j'aurais
problème je ris maintenant mais enfin
madame michu casquette pardonnez moi
mais par des moyens c'est ce qui fonde
le riz médecins sont effectivement
siffler hanouna dans vos monsieur qu'en
silence quand cyril hanouna oubliera de
verser votre salaire est bien
effectivement vous avez le droit se
serait dutil a exactement
je vous dis oui fabre est finalement
nous avons confisqué cpt de la nation
sommes exactement là nous n'avons pu
débuter la nation en chine nous n'avons
plus le droit effectivement demandé
je vais juste mettre vous saouler depuis
une heure dix ans casino études
on n'a pas besoin d'études est ce que
vous avez besoin d'une étude pour savoir
que si on roule mouret vite si nous
n'avons pas peur des accidents que les
autres de mourir yade est une question
de bon sens aussi
pas besoin d'études pour ça alors
monsieur je vais là bas oui défoncé et
va le défoncer quel bon sens dans ces
défis parce qu'il ya définitivement
disparu mais désormais être un exemple
parfait à votre propos aller chercher
les études celle qui vous disent qui
vous autorise à rouler à 140 quand ses
bananes a essayé de mélanger pas
deuxième fait pas du choc pour moi ça
marchera pas essayer effectivement très
sophistiquée avec moi ça marchera pas
manola parle d'un sujet depuis que je
viens de plateau à chaque fois qu'il est
mis en difficulté il détourne le sujet
madame vous parle maintenant d'accidents
circulation le sari madame j'ai une
question à vous poser si les décisions
que vous prenez ne sont pas basés sur
les éléments scientifiques à quoi vous
sert le conseil scientifique
le conseil scientifique émet des
recommandations que le politique est
libre dessus à mal le président de la
république d'ailleurs récemment à
connecter résultat tout l'intérêt ça ne
la raconte fabrice pavone vous en mettez
donc vous admettez libé que le port du
masque obligatoire constitue une
décision politique qui n'est pas
forcément fondée sur un élément
scientifique vous m'interrogez comme ben
oui mais bon effectivement des décisions
politiques
gilles verdez après avoir le résultat
est re division et vous vous vous rendez
compte de ce que vous dites qu'est ce
que vous dites aux gens de la côte
d'azur qui sont confinés aujourd'hui
parce que ça flambe abat jour 2b mac et
vierge est la dernière où le tout paris
michael di grappa de tous les jours
c'est la moselle où les mots vous êtes
fait enfumer
parce que vous êtes qui enfume équipe le
feu depuis le 2 janvier et que
finalement ça démontre puissamment que
ça ne marche pas le coût soit le genre
d'étude du ch toulouse avait parlé mais
quand vous êtes ça marche pas et que ça
pour être sorti monsieur c'est de dire
effectivement que quand on prend une
mesure attentes actuelles pour des
raisons politiques
eh ben ça peut conduire à des drames de
santé lui défonce merci c'est ce que je
voulais fait c'est moi pas tout mais
depuis fonds statuts c'est à dire quand
vous avez raison ma branche la santé un
sujet sanitaire à ma fille de vivre ou
revivre au le plus vite possible et
alarmes allemand et nous avons donc été
décidé alors madame et nous affrontons
vous met dans les tickets décision des
nations unies fiq à prendre et ce qu'a
incarné parfaitement présent la
république à trois semaines
on va voir ce combat seul dénominateur
regarder oui à 40%
non à 60% moyaux pas bon
bon c'est me fiche voilà c'est michmich
mais c'est donc assez lisse piges comme
60 40 une élection la famille chemises
jaunes oui effectivement gagné par 60/40
aiguille que ces niches
à 100% mais ça me choque c'est vrai la
raison vote à raison a dit m moi aussi
j'avais problème